ma semaine oui les gens m'ont pas écouté
et maintenant on est coincé on est à
court d'oxygène de produits médicaux de
tout le matériel respiratoire
on est définitivement à court de riz de
personnel on n'a pas suffisamment de
personnel on a échoué
les gens n'ont pas écouté ont continué
d'ignorer les recommandations des
centres pour le contrôle et la
prévention des maladies de se réunir je
comprends à quel point ces jours là sont
importants pour moi ils le sont tout
autant
ça fait des mois que je n'ai pas vu ma
famille notre gouvernement a également
tout gâcher il aurait pu recourir aux
défaillances production actes et
augmenter la fabrication d'équipements
de protection individuelle et d'autres
produits médicaux nécessaires mais ne
l'a pas fait
l'ensemble du pays dans une situation
très difficile en ce qui concerne
capacité à traiter les patients toute
sécurité et leur prodiguer les soins
dont ils ont besoin